but so I know I think Nisa just maybe
the best stumblings in the entire city
dad thinks his in the back but mine of
the business dumplings are basically
just little parcels of yumminess I'm
using ready-made dumpling wrappers you
can get them at oriental supermarket so
to get the rolling pin to make it a bit
thinner you get your mix I made this
earlier
it's just fried vegetables spices and
sauce tiny bit of water so it doesn't
get too wet and now just folding over
the dumpling leave it together like a
clamp and that is a perfect dumpling I'm
putting a wooden steam it in a pan of
boiling water to heat while I'm making
the rest of the dumpling
there's nothing in there it doesn't
smell of any fish with a bamboo dad
loves dumplings my brother you just
can't stay away
[Music]
you decided to give me a masterclass
[Music]
it's so annoying remember don't let your
adult or anything else distract you when
you've got something on the stove so
I'll show you how to do dumplings and
they won't be weird
wrinkly ones like dads that's my
dumplings ready to steam and wonder if
the guys have found the perfect la look
hey guys good dang look at the hair oh
no dad's coming hide Tilly's burn the
bamboo nice one too that's my time now
this is time for my date bye daddy foo
go now but boomers find out myself a job
the job lived on the floor drop my
dumpling gonna fall love you bye
I am so sorry that that's my sister my
dad exactly like my family it's fine
nine-one-one
we're dad's finally gone see in the
dumpling for about five minutes in the
clothes shop the girls are looking like
natural models and I can't wait to see
the clothes later back in the kitchen
and the dumplings are ready I'm serving
these with a soy sauce and sesame dip
car is this trying one it's really good
it was really good